[Musique]
on a 30 ans maintenant nos carrières
sont nazes des désastre on est à court
de jeu de société pour boire on a tous
envie de rencontrer l'amour de notre
rude mais le monde d'aujourd'hui n'est
plus aussi simple mais on n'est plus en
couple vous avez réussi à étouffer vos
ardeurs d'un coup mais votre dynamique
est incroyablement sexuel oui
[Musique]
alors qu'est-ce qui vous fait rire on se
moque de notre ami parce qu'elle sort
avec un vieillard
j'imagine que c'est moi
[Musique]
le nom de la joue cool et
détend comme moi cool et détendu allez
je vous entends je suis comment
je suis grand et curieux
on a peut-être pas été parfait
[Musique]
on avait peut-être pas tout compris de
la vie on débarque mais on était là les
uns pour les autres on fonctionne bien
je suis complètement d'accord
[Musique]